[موسيقى]
والله هو صار عنا قصف ويعني ومرعب جيراننا
ومرعب في شهداء ووقع الدور وقعت ع روسهم
فهنا بنتي لما درت انه الخص قريب منا يعني
بنتي تتصل فييه مكان انه كيف اهلي كيف
اهلي كان الاتصال مقطوع علينا كان يعني ما
صدقت بنتي يجي الاتصال عننا وتكلمني تطمن
[موسيقى]
علينا ايوه يما اي يا قما
عدي الو باجي على البحر هنا عشان اتواصل
مع بناتي اللي برا مع بنتي واطمن عنا
وتطمن هي علينا برضه بنت السكان بقطر بره
وبتصل فيها طمنها
قلبها قلقان يعني تعبان البد بتق يعني
بتنام بعياط ما بتصدق انه يجي اتصال وترن
علينا او احنا نرن عليها عشان تطمن علينا
ودار عمامي وعماتي في السعوديه برضك برنوا
علينا يطمنوا علينا يعني قولوا احنا
قلقانين عليكم يعني متوقعين اي لحظه نسمع
خبركم و
مستشهدين والله انا الاتصال عندي زي الميه
والهواء عندي انا لما بقبل اتصال مقطوع
يعني مش عايشين كانه مش عايشين برض في
عالم اخر
يعني انا كخريج وساط متعدده شغال
فريلانسر انقطع شغلي خلال فتره الاحتلال و
خلال فتره العدوان الاتصال والانترنت صار
صعب نقدر نتواصل مع العملاء في الخارج
بالتالي احنا يعني هذه لقمه عيشنا زي ما
بيقولوها ف بنقدرش انه نوقفها وغير انه
منقطع الانترنت عننا موضوع الاحوال او
الفلوس اللي بتجينا من بره ما بنقدر
نصرفها اذا انقطع الانترنت او الاتصال عن
غزه انا كشخصيات مع اقارب اللي برا و مع
العملاء اللي انا شغال معهم بالتالي الناس
كلها نفس
الشيء الانترنت عننا هنا على البحر ما
بيجي في كل المناطق بيجي في المناطق
العاليه زي ما انت شايف الناس ه واقفه على
تبه عاليه بيضطر انه يرفع الجوال بحث انه
يجي الارسال فبالتالي 95% من الناس يعني
يا دوبها جاي عندها النت شوي انها تسلك
امورها بحيث نتواصل مع الناس اللي
بره فعلنا الشريحه هذه بعتونا اياها من
بره طبعا اللي بيعرفنا اصحابنا قرايبنا
بعتولنا الشريحه هذه وشغالين هقيت عليها
زي ما انت شايف الكل شغال عليها لانه فيش
واي فاي هلقيت في الوقت هذا لازم يكون
عندك نت عشان تطمن على اللي الك واللي الك
يطمن عليك يعني زي هيك فعلناها وشغالين
عليها تقريبا 10 ايام نشتغل عليها ومنيح
يعني هي بت احسن يعني احسن من
بلاش والله يعني الحرب في كوم والقطع
الارسال وفيش اخبار مع حدا هذا كوم ثاني
فاحنا لما الشارح هذ تفعلت يعني ريحتنا
شويه بنطمن ايش بصير في الشمال وايش بصير
اللي برا بطمن علينا
كمان